on est revenu revenu revenu sur ce sujet
là un milliard de fois assimilé les
règles d'accord despatie s'est passé
relève souvent du parcours du combattant
on propose une réforme est capable de
cette nation là l'idée n'est pas
nouvelle la proposition date de
plusieurs années au québec et a même été
suggéré il ya plus d'un siècle
en france l'association québécoise des
professeurs de français qui regroupe des
centaines de membres du primaire à
l'université veut abolir des exceptions
et réduire les règles d'accord des
participes passés avec l'auxiliaire
avoir par exemple le verbe serai
toujours un variable et on peut prendre
les temps des hauts-lieux de travail je
suis exception le soin d'aller
travailler tôt 900 grammes à tikal qui
en avaient besoin une fausse bonne idée
selon cette enseignante de français qui
aident les élèves en difficulté depuis
une quinzaine d'années les réels
problèmes sans état de littératie évite
les jeunes ont des difficultés à aller à
écrire correctement la langue française
il l'accord des participes passés dans
tout ça c'est somme toute assez
anecdotique donc j'ai rien contre le
fait qu'on réforme c'est cet accord qui
est effectivement complexe mais ça ne
réglera pas tout chez les étudiants
l'idée de réforme divise
ça serait un peu simplifié la faire pire
réduire les erreurs de français ce
serait une question de tolérance mais
pas une question d'obligation souligner
cette linguiste dans faveur de la
réforme il est francophone font de moins
en moins l'accord du participe passé
avec avoir alors allez donc il est tout
à fait normal que la la langue s'adapte
au cabinet du ministre de l'éducation
jean françois roberge on répond qu'on va
étudier la demande de l'association
québécoise des professeurs de français
et qu'il est encore trop tôt pour
statuer quoi que ce soit ici olivier
lefebvre radio canada montréal